انضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنى
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه عميد الياس
نحن نتحدث اليوم عن معركه كبيره في
خانيونس وصفتها وصفها موقع ولا الاسرائيلي
بانها اصعب يوم في
المعارك كيف توصف انت هذه المعركه التي
تدور رحاها في خان يونس
حاليا زين العابدين هذه المعركه قد تكون
المعركه الفاصله اذا ما تحدثنا عن الشمال
وعن الوسط
هناك مرحله تقطيع ولكن مركز الثقل الاساسي
هو متوافر في خانيونس من هنا هذا الحشد
العسكري اكثر من ثمانيه الويه متعدده
الاسلحه من المظليين الى الوحدات الخاصه
الى المدرعات الى المشاد وبالتالي بالطبع
مع دعم جوي استخباراتي وحتى مسيرات هذا
الامر وهذا التركيز هو على مدينه خانيونس
لماذا لانه في هذه المدينه حسب
الاستخبارات وحسب ما تقول اسرائيل ان
القيادات الاساسيه موجوده في خانيونس
اثنين ان اغلب الرهائن ايضا موجودين في
خانيونس ثلاثه وهنا بيت القصيد وهذا امر
مهم جدا انه اذا كل الانفاق تنطلق من خان
يونس فاذا الانفاق بمسار عكسي قد تعود الى
خان يونس وقد يكون الباب الاساسي للدخول
الى شبكه الانفاق هي من خانيونس او في
مكان ما من خانيونس لانها مركز الثقل
وتقول بعض المعلومات ان هناك ما يقارب 160
م من الانفاق من اصل 700 كما ورد في ما
جريده نيويورك تايمز هي موجوده تحت
خانيونس من هنا هذا الحجد الكبير من هنا
هذه الضراوه كلما تقدم جيش الاحتلال كلما
صغرت المساحه نتحدث عن بين ثلاثه او 4 ك م
مربع للمساحه القتال ولكن هذا الامر يزيد
القتال ضراوه لانه المقاومه ستقاتل
بالخطوط الداخليه يعني في الدائره
الداخليه وجيش الاحتلال سيقاتل في الخطوط
الخارجيه وانا اعتقد ان الارض محضره لهكذا
نوع من هنا نرى
القناص الشواظ الكمائن
الار بي جي التي بي جي الياسين 105 وكل
هذه الاسلحه من ضمن منظومه ا يعني مساله
ال الممات المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه ما مدى
مصداقيه وما
مدى الامكانيه امكانيه الاعتماد عليها
بالنظر لانه مثل هذه المعلومات تم اشعتها
عن مجمع الشفاء الطبي من قبل وعن غزه
ايضا بالطبع هي عمليه استدراج كما يقال
بعلم الكمبيوتر زين
العابدين سيستم يعني انت عمليه خداع يعني
انت ترسل هذه المعلومه وتنتظر رده الفعل
يعني
اليوم الشيء المعروف والمعترف فيه ان لدى
الاسرائيليين او جيش الاحتلال عمى تكتيكي
عمى استخباراتي وبالتالي هو كلما تقدم
كلما جمع معلومات ان كان من خلال الاشتباك
مع المقاومه او حتى من خلال من يؤسر من
المقاومه ويتم استجوابه او من جمع
المعلومات من ارض الميدان وهذا الامر
يستلزم وقت طويل هي عمليه تخمين لانه عاده
في الحروب العسكريه يتم التخطيط للسيناريو
السيء وبالتالي يامل المهاجم ان يحصل
السيناريو الجيد او الممتاز من هنا خان
يونس لا تتطلب الثمان الويه او تسعه الويه
لانها لا يمكن كلها ان تقاتل في نفس
المكان العدد سيصبح كبير جدا وهي كبيره
عدديا من هنا يخطط للسيناريو السيء من هنا
حجد هذه القوه الكبرى
طيب ما هو الموقف بالنسبه لقوات جيش
الاحتلال اذا تبين ان معلوماته عن خان
يونس تشبه معلوماته عن مجمع الشفاء ولم
يخرج منها
بشيء اليوم عندما نتحدث عن مجمع الشفاء
نتحدث عن شمال غزه حتى الان حسب ما تبين
من ارض الواقع ان استنفدت اي معلومه
موجوده
في في الشفاء او في الشمال من هنا
الانتقال
الى الجنوب يعني عمليه انتقال المقاتلين
عمليه نقل الرهائن من الشمال الى الجنوب
اليوم ليس هناك من مكان اخر الا في خان
يونس وبالتالي سيتم التركيز على هذا
الموضوع هلا السؤال العكسي هو هل هناك من
حاسب هل هناك من حاسب جيش الاحتلال على ما
فعله في مستشفى الشفاء هو يدمر كل
المستشفيات وبدا اليوم بتدمير مصطفى ناصر
مستشفى ناصر حول او في غرب خان يونس يعني
المهم هو في المحاسبه طيب مقاربه المقاومه
لا شك ان المقاومه تعلم ان السيناريو
السيناريو الذي يحدث الان في خان يونس هو
سيناريو متوقع يعني حتى نحن ونحن من بعيد
نعرف ان المعركه ستنتقل من غزه الى
خانيونس
تباعا ما هي المقاربه التي بحوزه قوه
مقاومه غير نظاميه غير متناظره مع قوه
القوه
المهاجمه دائما كل فريق من خلال المعركه
يذهب الى نقاط القوه التي يتميز بها يعني
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعرض عضلاته بنقاط القوه
الميركافا
النمر وكل الاسلحه المتوفره لديه واليوم
يقال انه انزل عربه مدرعه جديده تعتبر من
الجيل الخامس بالمقابل المقاومه لديها منظ
زومه من السلاح وهي تملك اولويه وعي
المكان والزمان وهي قد حضرت لهذا الموضوع
هي تقاتل في بيئه مناصره لها مؤيده لها
وهي تعرف وهي تقاتل بطريقه مختلفه عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي او جيش الاحتلال هذا
الجيش عليه ان يدخل الى كل بيت ليتاكد ان
هذا البيت ليس مفخخا او لا يوجد فيه عنصر
قناص او حدا او احد من عناصر المقاومه
وبالتالي هذا الامر يعتمد على عامل المساء
والوقت يعني المقاومه تعتمد تترك المساحه
لتكسب الوقت ولكن في نفس الوقت عليها ان
تنزل اكبر قدر ممكن من الخسائر بالعدو
الاسرائيلي اثنين لا نزال نتحدث عن ور ا
يعني نتحدث عن ورقه الرهائن ايضا اها ما
يحدث اذا في من معارك في شمال غزه الان هل
هو منفصل عما يجري في خان يونس ام انه
مقصود لتخفيف الضغط عن خان يونس
ما يجري في شمال غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي
وسلوكه العسكري على الارض والمؤشرات تقول
انه بنى او يحاول بناء كوريدور من نت سريم
من نت سريم باتجاه شارع الرشيد لقطع
المنطقه الى يعني شمالا وسطا وجنوبا وبشكل
كامل وهو يثبت نفسه في هذه المرحله لعده
اسباب اذا تدخل تطلب الامر التدخل في
الشمال وحتى
منع الغزاويين من العوده الى الشمال قبل
تحرير الرهائن ايضا في الجنوب بنى كوريدور
معين مسلكي لوجستي ينطلق من الداخل
الاسرائيلي الى خان يونس الى عبسان
وبالتالي الى غرب خان يونس فقط ل بهدف
تطويق خان يونس من هنا عمليات الانزال
والتي بلغت ما يقارب الخمسه مرات والهدف
منها هو كسب الوقت تامين الامن العملاني
لانه ان تاخذ قوافل طويله بعيده غير محميه
هذا امر مهم ويعطي المقاومه اهداف سهله من
هنا عمليات الانزال وبالتالي التحدي
الاكبر هو من يجري في خانيونس وحتى
المقاومه يكفي يكفي هذا مثل معروف تماما
يقوله الراحل هانري كيسنجر تخسر المقا
تخسر اسرائيل اذا لم تربح و تربح المقاومه
اذا لم تخسر يعني عامل الوقت اساسي
وعامل الخسائر والاستنزاف هو شيء مهم
للمقاومه اشكرك شكرا جزيلا من بيروت
العميد الياس حم الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي